this time I think you can see the
inequalities are easy enough that we can
actually do this mostly no hands
actually we're talking about this with
regard to the circle on my inside or
outside I'm inside the circle ok so I'm
locked in there that's a good start with
regard to x equals 3 am I to the right
or to the left I'm to the left because
it's less than or equal to watch for
that could become one min a second and
then with regard to y equals minus 4
there at my bubble below I'm above ok
great so really what I'm looking at is
this section in here ok this section is
both inside the circle or not both it is
all love inside the circle and to the
left of x equals 3 and above y equals
negative 4 ok I'll do a bit more changes
to make it super obvious so we've got
our basic shape in there and now we need
to sort out the details ok so I've
already labeled on with a coordinates of
my three points of intersection but now
I need to know which ones are not need
to be included which ones aren't ok so
for instance let's have a look at this
guy down here ok minus 3 minus 4 is it
included or not remember it has to
satisfy all three inequalities ok and
the answer is it is not because look at
this guy right y is greater than by this
form this entire horizontal line is not
included it can't be included not
inclusive with the boundary ok so not
only do i see this must be a hollow
circle but for free I get that this must
also be a hollow circle that makes sense
everything along this boundary line is
not included also cannot be included ok
so I leave those hollow circles coming
up to the top right hand corner this is
the intersection between the circle is
the circle included or not it is and a
vertical line is the vertical line even
or not it is and both included so this
guy is filled ok holo holo filled ok
before we leave off um we need to get to
the lines but before we leave off on the
boys there are two other points now that
I know which I'm going to be relevant to
this bounder yeah good I've got this
intercept over here and I've got this
intercept up here these two these two
are outside so they're irrelevant to me
okay and because it's a rip circle of
radius 5 you're a negative 5 here and
five up there yep oh sad include the
intercept when like the lion doesn't go
right I mean it cuts across vehicle yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah good so I've got a
circle coming those are the only two
positive so for the intersect with the
axes that don't worry about the same
time i bought these guys right these
guys in here so I got negative 4 and
I've gone for it now it's worth noting
so I know it's not bad like more
information is always better than less
it just gets quite a bit now it's worth
mentioning right look at how much
information is on this diagram okay um
this might be worth three or four marked
are you gonna lose a mark because you
leave off a single value not likely not
likely because there's so much
information there that if you can
demonstrate most of it it's like great I
this students as I'm assessing their
ability to navigate this region
correctly they've got all the right bits
and they've missed out like one seventh
of the information however many points
there are okay but still it's about
dentistry do I understand the way this
region works and all the Queensland
relevant to it okay one last thing one
last thing we have some boundary lines
that we need to fill in or more filling
right so let's start with a circle stop
in a circle the circle is included okay
so which part of the circles including
which I is not answer the part is
satisfies both of these other linear
inequalities right so it looks to me
like I'm getting this section over here
because that section and that's section
only I should say that arc is above y is
equal to minus 4 and to the left of x
equals 3
ok what else started to include x is
equal in three good yeah I've got that
guy there inclusive of the battery so
that's the vertical line and I already
noticed before when I was trying to work
out those circles that this guy down
here is not included so he remains
dotted and that's it